this podcast is sponsored by better help
what is better help my friends better
help is customize online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to therapy is all about
deepening your self-awareness and
understanding because sometimes we don't
know what we want or why we react the
way we do until we talk things through
if you're thinking about starting
therapy give better help a try it's much
more affordable than in-person therapy
and you can be matched with therapists
in under 48 hours give it a try and see
why a bunch of people are doing it my
friends discovered your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com genius
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
help.com genius dude that's all I'm
saying this guy has no friends or no
friends that tell them to shut the [__]
up you know what I was thinking that
poor kid yes
that's [__] up
in five four three two one what's up
everybody welcome to another episode of
The Genius brain podcast we have the
reoccurring co-host Ed parkvp what's up
uh he won't be here for quite a while
because this [__] go to Seattle
for a month sorry I I thought I told you
I literally said it like five minutes
ago
he said I mean you said you're gonna go
to Seattle I didn't know for how long
though but right it's a whole last month
dude a whole month run the store yeah my
mom's going to Korea and she hasn't been
since she immigrated here so that's like
40 years that is a long [__] time
like she's gonna feel like she went into
a time machine right and then fast
forwarded because when we watched dramas
and stuff and like she's she really just
Daydreams it and like really wants to
ride the subway yeah
there was still like squatty potties
with like no Plumbing like interesting
places they have a car yeah
so I think she's gonna like step into
the future when she gets there dude e
for me not being there for uh 20 years
it was weird just because you know as a
four 14 year old I remember what it was
like and then you know being 34 and
going that I'm like this is so different
because in the United States I've you
know we've been here for 20 years right
it still looks the same you know 20
years ago now it looks relatively the
same there are some spots that just
never change yeah
but uh in Korea like especially in Seoul
like downtown it's like
a future city that you're trying to
build yeah just everything there is so
streamlined
um things are highly accessible streets
are really clean it's just very high
tech so like
let's say 20 years ago before when I saw
uh Sacramento right yeah Sacramento like
there's new cooler buildings new cooler
restaurants or something like that right
still relatively looks the same
neighborhoods relatively look the same
right oh you have an Applebee's now yeah
what is this chilies
I've seen these commercials
yeah but you know you go to Korea in the
span of 40 [__] years she has she's
gonna her mind's gonna be blown dude
yeah yeah I mean it's
the story she tells about it is just so
long ago it's not relatable so when she
watches movies like chingu or have you
heard a big bet like Casino
it's on Hulu uh it's what a championship
old boy oh [__] it's like his first
drama he's went back to television is
she gonna bring like gifts that they
already have over there and [__]
because like you know did you need
double a batteries
do you need deodorant she goes even
further back like the Korean War she
starts bringing military rashes
yeah
baked beans bro you know we make jokes
about this but I think I said about this
I said this on the podcast before but
years ago because I you know our our
country was rebuilding when you went to
Korea you had to bring things like you
don't just come empty-handed in general
you're not supposed to but they would
ask for a Centrum shampoo lotion
um [__] walnuts like right right like
nuts and fruits and such right like nuts
right which is so weird right and so
well not Foods because of yeah
agriculture when we were
Mariel's mom when we went to Korea she
had us bring all this [__] because
she was like oh they they liked this
stuff they don't have that there and the
Muriel was like yeah they do
your face
she was like they have almonds yeah they
do so we go there we give it to him they
appreciated her because they're also
older so they like it but then we went
into a grocery store that I was like
there's [__] hella almonds here right
it's just all there was a lady selling
almonds out in the street so I'm like
what the [__] is this so you'd have to
bring like american-centric American
thing I did the things that you do bring
to Korea that they like a lot is a lot
of a designer things that are uh cheaper
here right it's so expensive in Korean
North Face
my face is a brand out there like and
North Face over there like Nike is a
little more expensive Adidas is more
expensive so if you go to Hawaii right
in Hawaii there's this outlet mall and
there's one store that every [__]
Korean goes to Lacoste
and Ralph Lauren right so that Lacoste
in Hawaii there the employees speak
Korean because they have to because
they're all Korean
alligator t-shirt
and so they're literally just hyped by
Lacoste and stuff just because I mean I
would be too if I'm going to a country
and the [__] that I want is like I don't
know what half the price I'd [__] buy
that [__] immediately yeah so um when we
also had a friend uh Mariel's like
tongshang that came from um Korea and
then she showed us around Korea when we
were there not too long ago last year in
spring time goes wise fast
um yeah that was a year ago I went
through a year ago yeah I feel like I
just left what
trippy but we were there and um
do you know what she decided to bring
back [__] like 20 bottles of
everything but Bagel seasoning from
Trader Joe's
full seasoning yeah so if you guys don't
know like there's something called
Everything But everybody knows it's
called Everything But Bagel seasoning
it's the season that they put on the
Sesame yeah so Trader Joe's has their
thing
people [__] know about Trader Joe's
in Korea and they want all the snacks
from Trader Joe's mmm
interesting like the way all the you
know white people and such like
everybody comes to K-Town go to the
Asian market to find the snacks yeah
have you seen this shrimp chips you know
it was so weird that they chose Trader
Joe's yeah so because Trader Joe's
Doritos well Trader Joe's too is like a
California thing too so it's only in
California guess who else people in
Hawaii so when I when I went um back I
was asking my friends like what do you
guys want they're like anything from
Trader Joe's I'm like what the [__]
Trader Joe's
maybe they should just open a [__]
store in Hawaii that's if they open up a
store in Hawaii Trader Joe's would be
packed out the I mean it's already
packed out the ass here what's the deal
I don't know they don't want to organic
or something like that it's not non-GMO
Trader Joe's is interesting like they
have I don't know what their deal is
exactly but they definitely have a lot
of products that are from
um a lot of mom and someone say mom and
pops but smaller companies right like
these snacks who create right you know
locally sourced exactly right okay so uh
there is an application form that you
could pick up from Trader Joe's to
actually apply to have your products go
in there which is which we wanted to do
with like shrimp Daddy and stuff like
that obviously it didn't go through but
in the future if we do get our shrimp
daddy sauce it would be great to have it
at every Trader Joe's in California it
might be powder matcha powder maybe it
would be pretty damn amazing but Trader
Joe's too like I think that's how it is
with Target too right uh you have to
apply for it to have your products in uh
Target to be readily available that's
why uh Blogilates Cassie ho if you don't
know all of her products are in Target
by the way if you guys don't know who
Cassie ho is Cassie host started this um
Channel years ago and actually Muriel
was a big fan of hers because while she
was in Taiwan she wanted to stay fit and
um she started watching her Pilates
videos and this was before she met me
this was like 10 11 years ago right Mary
was living there and uh from that point
on like Cassie has blown up her Empire
right and on top of that too on her
social media game is so good because and
I just messaged her recently and we were
just I was complimenting her and then
she was you know I was just really proud
of her yeah because of what she has done
she is one of the few creators out there
that I've seen that has been able to not
only survive
being on social media for x amount of
years she transferred into another
medium which is like selling products
but not only selling products doing it
without having to sell her soul right
you know what I mean yeah she creates
amazing amazing products so amazing that
[__] um what's it called Shane bit
offer right they [__] straight up
stole her entire design
did she have patents on that too I think
I I'm pretty sure she does but you know
it's like what Jack ma said did you see
that thing with Jack ma said uh years
ago before trying to shut him down
you'll have to remind me so Jack mob he
was being interviewed and there was a a
reporter that was asking him he goes so
what do you feel about your company you
know stealing designs from all these
other companies and
um how does your company survive being
sued and stuff like that it was
something along those lines and he just
goes sue me I'll make more money than
you could ever sue me for
so he doesn't give a [__] yeah and these
that's like what these companies like
[__] so just to give you guys reference
I'm pretty sure people have shot from
like Sheen and you know Forever 21 these
are fast fashion brands right so in
clothing they don't care about quality
they don't care about care about the
stitching they don't care about where
the design comes from they just steal
from everybody else they created for
cheaper and they sell it right but
obviously when you buy cheap clothes
everybody knows stuff like h m Forever
21 you wash your shirt once you got a
halter top yeah
it like bleaches itself you're like what
the [__] I'd even put in Bleach I know
like those are that's what fast fashion
is a shirt see-through now
it's like disintegrated it's
disintegrating holy [__] yeah and you
know you get what you pay for they are
literally the definition of you get what
you pay for so Cassie ho she has really
amazing designs she really reinvents a
lot of the things that she does for
stuff that she wants to see in clothes
right it's what we do with secret
society too but she does it for Fitness
right yeah and so like for example I
think one I mean obviously I got a dick
but she got the I do
she developed um women leggings that's
anti-camel anti-camel so I saw that one
and I thought that was [__] amazing
genius she's just doing things and you
know this is what Innovation is with a
lot you know uh I read this somewhere
Innovation is creating something that
people need that they don't know yet and
that's what she's doing with a lot of
her stuff her stuff it looks really good
and I think a lot of her fan base
appreciates the work that she puts in
because originally she went to a fashion
school and she was designing her own
[__] so she's taking a skill that she's
developed over years and and she built
this [__] Empire I I look up to this
girl a lot yeah like she's amazed at
what she does so every time she puts out
these new pieces of clothes obviously
it's not for me but I [__] love all
of her pieces it's so good man I gotta
apologize to her because uh about three
years ago I ran into her
and then she had seen how I had
transformed from keto uh-huh and she
wanted all this keto advice so I just
gave it to her
it did not work out for it like ruined
her body oh for reals like she was not
made to do keto when I was like what
happened
um I think basically a lot of Asian
women can't do keto
um all of the things she had to do
exogenously with like nutrients because
she wasn't getting what she could and
just eating 70 fat that that led her to
transform the way she was doing her
nutrition now I'm not saying that I'm
the Catalyst for that but I was like
yeah and keto's not for everyone yeah
then I you know I was reading things
about that too where they're talking
about just like the Asian diet in
general it's very grain heavy yeah so
like a lot of Asian people doing keto it
doesn't really match up with us very
well I think it's the Mongolian DNA part
maybe yeah or something right and I was
I was streaming the other day and when
we were streaming people were asking me
it's like oh you should try keto I'm
like listen guys I've tried it and I
could not do it it hurts
it's it hurts well I was explaining too
I don't I think a lot of people fail
keto because they don't realize how
intricate it is right like you've done
it and you know how intricate it is like
what it takes to be on this uh like to
stay in ketosis and so when we were
streaming I was telling people you know
you still have to be in a caloric
deficit like you still have to count
that stuff and they were like what I'm
like yeah that's how hard it is like
because on a regular diet where you're
on a caloric deficit right so people
think that when they're on keto they
don't have to worry about calories right
right no you still have to or they they
have too much protein and not enough
fats and then those proteins because
they don't get processed they just turn
back the carbs in your uh Olympic system
I believe I forget but yeah it gets
stored back and so that's why it's
strict macros too like this has to be 70
fat and you can't have more than 20 25
grams yeah unless you're like
bodybuilding and that's what I'm saying
like because that's how strict it is
right so on a typical diet right when
you are calorie counting uh so we'll
just talk about like this weight loss
portion anyways where you could even do
something like this right let's say
within the week right let's say your
caloric intake uh you you calculated it
out right and you're really overweight
on average you're eating about 4 000
calories a day right which is basically
what I was doing
um
I could pull back 200 calories right and
just do 3 800 but let's say uh Monday
Tuesday Wednesday Thursday I did that
right but on Friday I ate 300 calories
above that well what I could do on the
next day I could subtract it and then
transfer it over to the next day and
then do that within the week I forgot
what that's called but I heard my
dietitian friend was telling me like you
could actually
um sub it through the next week and then
fix it oh the next day right so just
reduce that caloric amount on the next
day and you should be fine
keto is not like that when you're out of
ketosis you knock yourself out of it
just to start all over again oh my God
it's literally like dying in Mario in
like the hardest setting you just die
and you have to start from the very
beginning that's how it goes when you
were on keto and then you got off of it
did you gain a lot of weight fast or was
it just slow I did I did by the way I
think I said 20 25 grams I think I meant
to say 20 of your Macros oh okay protein
yeah that's really [__] low by the
way Jesus Christ yeah uh it's not it's
it's it's tough to do but so my whole
internal like structure changed because
I was just running on burning fat
I didn't have sugar for like a year you
know and then um when I was I had a
mental health crisis and then
um you know when you get depressed it's
hard to put something in your mouth and
and it's like to swallow I was having
that so I had to make chook you know I
had to make rice and hot water just to
eat that's crazy yeah so I had to get
off keto right so interesting right so
I've like since the beginning of
February is a month now I lost about
like 10 pounds right and
um
not counting calories or anything just
eating a lot more Whole Foods and taking
out processed carbs right or uh just not
a lot of if the carb doesn't have a lot
of fiber I just don't eat it uh just
because I have a pretty terrible
relationship with like bread and rice
you know I could kill like fried rice I
could obliterate fry rice like nothing
dude like four servings worth I could
probably have easy
like I had recently I on a day where I
just wanted I was like you know what I
don't even want meat I just want carbs
today so I went to get I got uh yeah and
I also had fried rice
I ate that I felt like [__] from and I
ate that like at 12 o'clock because I
fast in the morning I eat at 12. yeah I
felt like [__] all the way till about
like 10 P.M and I had I felt hazy I had
this headache right your your shoulders
were weak like right it just I felt sick
I felt queasy because and by the way I
am eating carbohydrates right so but I'm
getting it from whole food sources right
whether it's whole grains or uh a lot of
fruit and veggies and then when you have
the processed stuff you do like it feels
shitty yeah and I I was kind of shocked
I was a little
especially because I started you know
making healthier food choices only in a
month and already I've adjusted to that
I think you know I always had this
conversation with other people when you
know I was I had a conversation with
somebody who the [__] was it but either
way I was telling them about you know me
figuring out what processed carbs do to
me right
um especially when you make better
choices and they're like oh you're
getting old I was like I don't think
it's an age thing because I think I've
always felt like this I just didn't care
yeah you know and when you're you're
used to I was used to it so like when we
made this joke before I was like dude
diarrhea was just every day every day
you know that's just how it's supposed
to add solid poop you're like
something's wrong yeah I went to my
doctor I was like dude you know my poop
was solid today can you check me out
he's like uh congratulations
congratulations what's the problem you
just heard it it was solid
but now that you know I've I've gotten
healthier it's become my norm and so
when I'm not like that it feels weird so
when I went back to Sacramento for those
two months and I went from 202 all the
way to 217 for two months after two
months I gained about 15 pounds it felt
like [__] I felt terrible not from like
a mental state of oh I don't like what I
see in the mirror because in my mind I
look the same yeah it's just
I felt lethargic I felt [__] tired
and I just didn't like the way I felt
and everybody knows too if you're
actually if you're of any culture right
but I'm speaking from a korean-american
perspective you go home you you get
there I tell my mom listen
don't make too much food because I'm
gonna go out and eat with my friends so
I'll just eat dinner with you guys don't
make breakfast got it next day she
[__] kills a thousand animals and
puts it on the [__] shape right and I
go listen what did I just say I can't
eat this food I'm gonna go out to eat oh
so you don't love me right woman I will
punch you in your [__] dude
and then I eat the food right and she
goes
yeah oh my gosh which means why are you
eating so much you [__] [__] ass
lighting
and she's like and then the next day
this is what happened the next day right
she makes the food I don't eat it at all
right and then she gas likes me she goes
why aren't you eating the food I was
like you just told me I was eating too
much she goes but this is only once in a
while how come you can't eat this food I
was like fine [__] it I eat it right she
goes you should eat a lot less I'll
[__] [__]
I will punch you in your face what is
your intent what are you doing today
you're driving me crazy I was losing my
[__] mind dude yeah but then look I
enjoyed the food and I love my mom's
food my mom can cook so [__] good
dude it's pretty [__] amazing right
I'm just I was just having conversation
with my roommate about this the other
day because
um I was thinking about the spaghetti I
made right and I just thought about the
worst [__] dish my mom ever made
she's trying to make a chicken with
[__] linguine
oh beautiful that's right your mom can't
come my mom can't cook so when I hear
people like you and everything my mom's
cooking's the best and I was like I have
no I don't relate I don't get it I don't
know what that means man let me tell you
this you know whose other mom can't cook
[__] marrow's mom can't cook so one
time
so this was actually it was very
um I appreciate it a lot right because
Mario's Mom doesn't cook she's the
youngest daughter out of her whole
family she never had to cook and then
Mariel's dad cooks really well so we're
at the house
oh no she comes over to our apartment at
the time when I was living in Pasadena
before I got this house
her mom brings right and I'm like oh she
doesn't cook so I wonder what she's she
opens up this kimchi Tiga and bro I
didn't know people can burn spam
spam was burnt was black oh no
and then Not only was it black you could
tell she's never used a knife before
because they're spammed like just in the
block form and there's like a thin slice
even cool I eat it all the way through
and then all she did was put water and
kimchi juice and that was it
[__] you're like yo what the what the
[__] is this and I ate it and I said it
was delicious because she put so much
effort into it but it was so bad but
does Mariel love it Mariel like this she
goes oh this is good right because
that's what she grew up on right
everyone's mom's chiga is like always
the best not my mom's but my enemies
um I don't I don't think it's the best
kimchi in the world either but it tastes
the exact same every time I go there
that's why I go back for it you know but
necessarily I don't think it's the best
you get out there and look my mom can
cook really well to to the point where
like
there's definitely obviously restaurants
in Korea that cook better dishes that
she can right but my mom is such a
[__] hater I told her recently to
watch this um
this documentary on Netflix that they've
been doing these Series so there's one
for it was pork belly Rhapsody because
Korean people have an obsession with
pork right right right and those hot and
woo Rhapsody where they're kind of um
basically it's about beef where we have
Korean beef which cream beef is very
delicious by the way and then there's
this other one where they do about stews
and soups so if you guys ever wanted to
if somebody ever asked me like
definitive definitively what is Korean
food I would say fermented fermented
side dishes and stews this is what we
grew up on there are so many different
variations of soups and stews that we
really really love so I told my mom
about this documentary and I was like oh
there's this one place in Jeju that
serves the ship she goes that shit's not
even good yeah I'm like what the [__] I
was like did you see it she goes I
didn't see it yet but I can make it no
you hey hey
she's not even cute
[Laughter]
so
not too long ago there was a girl like
Muriel is not the the jealous type at
all right and I can never like gauge
what is her level of jealousy when it
comes to other women and she doesn't
know that she does this but then I've
I've experienced it a few times right
where it's like some girl who I
personally don't find attractive right
but it'll just be on your your explore
page right and I look at that and I
remember it was a specific photo where
the girl was on a beach right she was in
her bikini but I click I saved the thing
right not because of her I say that
because she was doing a real about
destination spots for vacations right
right I was like oh that's because I
always go to Hawaii for beaches but it
was like someone it was like a hidden
place in California and I'm like cool
and she goes oh you think she's cute and
I'm like
what
she's like she's not even that cute um I
what I've never seen this side I'm like
first of all I'm just bookmarking this
California destination so we can go
later yeah right and and I'm being
really honest she wasn't no she was she
was cute right but it wasn't it's not
why you say saved it the post yeah it
was it was like uh spots in California
that had the best beaches so I wanted to
click it that's when you have to go
that's not what it looks like yeah it
really isn't because we actually
bookmarked one of those beaches and we
went to Santa Barbara yeah because I it
had like a beach in Santa Barbara that I
wanted to go to but I was like oh that's
that was a first I've never uh seen her
do that before a little weird dude a
little [__] weird maybe it's like
um could it be the certain color she
wears that she thinks she could wear
better I always wonder about this too
because I I've experienced it too I
can't tell them these stories I'll tell
you later yeah but I'm also is like why
why because I don't even give a [__]
about this person at all yeah no matter
how much I try to convince him there's
just like they just hate that picture
it's it's always what I found out too
and I've asked a couple of my homegirls
about this right where they go sometimes
it's like a girl that reminds him of
another girl that they [__] hate and
they just look like that so it has
nothing to do with the specific girl
itself or anything about them it's like
PTSD that they have about some other
[__] right and then just treat them
like they're that Enemy by the way not
[__] and like what I call women I'm
like that's what they're thinking yeah
but that's what it attains to be we
don't know we're just like they just
have this bomb ass Pizza
I wonder because it could be like I
don't know the the destination right it
just letters that now we I have to go
there to cover my ass
who are we going next week
look at some other posts like hey I just
want this bikini set from Victoria's
Secret okay I'm wearing it
[Laughter]
yeah so like Korean people they love
like gigas right that's like my [__]
[__] and uh recently and listen
I appreciate what this guy does a lot
right specifically for what he does for
in terms of uh visibility for Korean
food it's Chef David Chang yeah right
um however he puts up a lot of [__]
that I don't personally enjoy right
specifically about Korean food and look
they're like well David he's a
professional chef I don't give a [__]
I'm Korean too and [__] you
can't even speak Korean right by the way
I don't hate David I actually like him a
lot but he put up this thing that
actually bothered me and the reason why
it bothered me is because somebody
posted like a lot of people were tagging
me in this right or they were saying
like oh we had no idea that this is how
you're supposed to eat Korean food and
I'm like what are you talking about I
see this video and he's teaching people
how to eat he goes you never put your
rice in the soup says
Who David Chang shouldn't [__] what the
[__] that is the way to ichigan like
that's how Korean people do it that
sounds like Superstition
if he said because it's bad luck I would
have been like this is how you do it
[__] you don't know [__] and I'm
hopefully he's joking and I think he
might be joking but I thought it was at
first I don't think he is it's like why
would you know he was showing people how
to eat Korean chicken hey dummy
literally Korean people say this pop
model Mogul that means dunk your rice in
the soup
right
it's every [__] place they went to
good guess what they did yeah they took
the ride
to the soup that's how most Korean
people eat their chickens so many
Koreans are like ratio eaters right yeah
yeah like they got to get everything in
one spoon that's why Santa is like such
a big thing have you seen that video of
um this girl makes chili American Texas
style chili for her grandparents and
then they like make like some palette
wraps and [__] right but then you start
seeing like how much they need to get
everything in one big bite and so yeah
it makes sense of course we dip our rice
and I think that's the thing that uh
like Asian food does really well right
is that we're very good at balancing
flavors out so that everything goes in
one bite and it's just on top of that
too like
for example if you guys eat uh I love
American barbecue right but that's a
definitively like food decadence right
to the point almost to a fault sometimes
right mind you guys know I love Adam
Perry length stuff but Adam Perry link
is different because he serves his food
with the side A Generous amount of
pickles slaw and jalapenos right because
you need acid for this like heavy food
Korean people do that very well Thai
food Vietnamese there's no dish that you
eat that is so palette heavy that you
don't have some type of citrus or acid
to break that up with Korean food it's
that's how it is right we have
um
which is this vinegary sugary soup that
you eat with this white white noodle
these two separate things just boom this
is perfect and it's so [__] good
sometimes when I with American food I
get extreme palette fatigue or I'll eat
it and then I'm like oh this is a little
bit too much that's why I can't have a
steak bigger than eight ounces
you don't say like I'll say this too
like with steak right think about it
like this where you know when it comes
to like French and American foods yeah
um obviously not all I'm just talking
about mother sauces or whatever like
you'll go to a steakhouse you'll eat
you'll get a rib eye steak and they'll
be like oh do you want a bernaise with
this which is essentially mayonnaise hot
mayonnaise with already a fatty ribeye
steak right or you'll get
um another type of fatty sauce or
whatever the hell that it is right
versus like if you go to like
um a Thai restaurant you'll get the
crying tiger sauce right I forgot I
don't know how to pronounce it but that
is lime juice fish sauce chilies bright
herbs and then you it kind of balances
out the fatty steak that you have and
this is like the food experience that I
enjoy a lot with Asian food
but going back to what David Chang was
saying like don't let other people
dictate like how you eat that food like
there's no really real rules for Korean
food so was he saying reason why like
you don't dip your rice in your soup is
because it'll change the flavor I think
it was saying because it's too hot but
I'm like do you don't you understand
Korean people love pain
that's why you always go
we we always dude that's what you know
the funny thing is
uh I I had a white buddy
and let's just call him Peter so Peter I
remember the first thing that he said I
remember I felt a certain way about it
but I understood later on he goes do you
[__] cream people just like eating
lava
I'm like what what do you mean it goes
dude like you because we went to go eat
a BCD yeah
it's boiling how are you eating this
food I'm like you're supposed to eat it
like that he goes you guys are [__]
nuts like it's boiling and I thought
about I'm like yeah it's kind of hot
right I mean you think about like going
to saunas and hot tubs and like kimchi
buns are like yeah that shit's really
hot too I don't know yeah we like
extreme versions of everything so like
we needed like really warm in our
stomach to deal with the weather I don't
know it has to be scalding hot like if I
get soup that's just warm I'm like dude
Heat this [__] up you're trying to get
me sick yeah are you nuts like I want
the [__]
not the dangle dude
I need my tongue to feel like sandpaper
like when you see like American people
eat soup just think about this like in
like let's say in a commercial like
tomatoes uh Campbell's Soup yeah you see
that they get it with the Spoonful this
is how Korean people do it
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude everything is an onomatopoeia
Korean okay yeah
everything's an onomatopoeia to us we
wear our emotions on our mouths yo think
about it like this if you guys watch
Korean dramas right have you seen Korean
girls eat pip
holy [__] dude dislocate their jaw
oh this is the way yeah or when we do
some right yeah you'll see like I will
forever remember
watching my friends eat me eat some
right because we went to a Korean
barbecue spot that had they they
actually had kidney which a lot of
Korean barbecue spots are doing now but
they didn't back in the day right it was
just but there was a sambar and it was
the one next to it was all you can eat
spot that we used to always go to not
move the one across the street
um Stone barbecue and they had candy and
then I wrapped it up I put a bunch of
rice and it was so packed and I went
as you should as I should and they were
looking at me like bro just make it
smaller I'm like no you're supposed to
eat it with a burrito like like a
burrito like bites at a time you know
like you made a sum and then you just
take small bites like that doesn't make
sense that's not confused
python dude what are you talking about
hahaha
there's no swallowing here I asked my my
dad about that right and then I also
asked Muriel's dad and they kind of had
the same response where they were saying
that it kind of came about in his mind
from what he remembers it's like first
of all military yeah because you're
always on the go and you have to eat
your stuff yeah you have to eat your
[__] in like less than five minutes so
you just kind of grab it and go and also
from the war so you were always on the
go you were always super poor having to
work do do a lot of [__] so people would
just kind of eat things in big bitefuls
because they had to be on the move so it
was out of necessity and it just became
a part of our cultural cultural
addressed that on Reddit or other places
like with mukbang becoming a thing in
American culture now is like why do
Koreans eat with their mouths full like
you have so much food in your mouth and
you just spend your time chewing it's
like okay
if they didn't rape and pillage
yesterday
I think we eat
darn [__] resources okay it is what
it is why we love [__] spam and
[__] Vienna sausages that's all we
had it is what it is guys but uh
but watching that like that chiga stuff
it always makes me salivate because I
love stews and soups yeah and so like
when I when sometimes when I see a lot
of people who are on food and once again
like I said I want a preface I love
David Chang but hearing him whether it
was a joke or whatever whatnot right I
don't think it was a joke for him to do
that and he has such a big influence and
for people are like oh I gotta educate
my friends I'm like [__] man this is
this is where I have sometimes problem
with like food influencers just like you
don't these white people don't know [__]
and now they're going to take this
information and be all snobby about our
food when that's not even true like if
he had said oh don't put your chopsticks
in your rice that makes sense that makes
sense because of a cultural uh what do
you call that faux pas right because it
represents the like Buddhist uh the
Indian rules yeah like that so it's like
okay like that makes sense like if
you're eating out with your friends but
then if you imagine some white guy not
dipping his rice in his soup oh it's
Jeff David King told him dude I just
imagine me eating at the table and then
a white person looking at me is like bro
you know you're not supposed to do that
it's like dude man yeah
like who like now I have to [__] you up
those are fighting words what did you
say just say to me
in what world like just for you guys if
you want a reference just watch the
documentary on Netflix and you'll see
every time they eat the soup they mix
the rice in the soup and they eat it
it's one of the best things on Earth the
only reason why you wouldn't do that is
if you're sharing the pot yeah
it's something we do right but then we
get our own bowls not like this when we
eat lamyon right right what did you do
after when there's soup in there
perfume
this isn't that [__]
[__] are you talking
package yeah
yeah two packs is too much yeah right
one Pack's not enough so the in between
was to put [__] rice in here yeah
yeah yeah we need those carbs and it's
so weird I don't get bothered by
anything but that [__] bothered me
that bothered me a lot I'm like you're
Korean dude you should know better
I I yeah I have no clue like maybe I
feel like his intent was like a cultural
hey check this fact though or whatever
like here's one I heard uh Anthony
Bourdain say you're not supposed to dip
your fish in the soy sauce you dip the
oh you're not supposed to dip the rice
you're supposed to dip the fish of the
soy sauce for sushi I forget it was one
way or another it's because he's saying
then you won't start mixing the fish
taste into the soy sauce and put that on
other fish and I was like okay that
makes sense but I don't know if that's
true or not well if it's for sushi right
that's not true so I'm only saying this
because I know this from a bunch of
sushi chefs right you know Japanese ass
[__] yeah yeah they tell you
not to dip the rice into there because
the soy sauce and the Wasabi is for the
fish so you'll see it upside down Okay
okay right and then you know I remember
too they
people were getting so pretty every the
food stubbery is very weird and once
again I'm actually very particular to
the point where I like to respect food
cultures but if you make stuff at home
you make even however the [__] you want
that's how you eat it at home it's the
education process that bothers me in
this house we do not tip our rice in our
chicken okay kids I just want to go to
one of his restaurants look at him dead
in the eye and put rice in a suit and
then [__] eat it right in front of
them it's like yeah
and then he doesn't know what you're
saying
dude why is this guy speaking Chinese
Love David chase that bothered me only
because of like people felt like they
were re-educating themselves about like
Korean food Korean food was made a lot
of our stuff if you realized
we just mishmashed a bunch of [__] yeah
like and it's so delicious there's no
rule I never had a rule in my house or
any of my other Korean friends house
where they're like oh you don't eat it
like that they just go yeah so that's
another thing my like my mom's mom so my
Harmony the Yoda Harmony she was a great
cook but I never seen a measuring cup in
her [__] house ever but what do they
do just Decades of trial and error right
are you ready
and they eat the whole thing anyway
if you ever wanted to impress a Korean
person I want you to complain how salty
something is but still eat the whole
food yeah you better keep eating it that
was my dad again my dad would do that
[__] he goes
people
if you don't like it stop it don't
[__] eat it
oh my God are you just complaining just
to complain
it was just a weird thing like
um and and the funny thing is uh a lot
some of my chef buddies too they go oh
do you measure things they kind of
sometimes you give me that little oh how
do you know how it tastes it's like you
guys know how it is man yeah
um you just taste as you go like for
example I make I love that that crying
tiger sauce right I think I think a
nickname for it is crack sauce right but
I make my own variation of it right and
so sometimes on Instagram I'll show the
food that I make like show me the recipe
sorry don't know it like I know the
technique how to make it
but I'll do what my mom says to me so
much
and then yeah
because I just tasted and I go oh it's
not right then I'll fix it right so
today I made the uh the Tigers crying
and I made it to my palette right so the
ingredients are this for anybody who
wants to make it and there's different
variations of this
fish sauce garlic
um cilantro Thai Chili sugar now the
different variations is what on tip
depending on how authentic you want to
make it
palm sugar
um uh what type of fish sauce that you
use and the variations that I've seen
from a lot of different Thai people
sometimes they add shallot right or some
people will add green onions a little
bit to it yeah but everybody makes it a
little different depending on how they
do it in their household and so for me I
do that and then I add chili oil to it
right a little bit which is not how it's
supposed to be but that's how I enjoy it
if you ask me for a recipe I wouldn't
[__] know because I that have been
there a little bit of this I taste oh
let me add some more lime to it maybe in
in David Chang's household his is
something his his mom's mom did to his
great grandma did great great grandma
did for a long time and they forgot the
reason why they don't do it yeah like
there was one guy who was telling me
like
um his mother-in-law would come in and
then she'd love cooking steak for him
because he's he's white his his wife is
Korean
and she would always cut this piece of
the steak off when she cooked it or
whatever and then so his wife at home
would always cut a piece of the steak
off and cook the steak this certain way
and so he was like why do you keep
cutting this piece of steak off and
she's like because my mom did and my
grandma did okay this is the way we cook
it and then he was so frustrated with
like just literally just as a hunk of
meat left right that he went to his
Harmony in law I was like why do you cut
the piece of steak off like that she's
like my pan is too small
foreign
but then like when it got passed down
like no this is how we cook it like it
becomes like that that's hella funny
which is kind of like the plot in in um
your name right yeah yeah yeah yeah
tools but over hundreds of years they
forget the reason why they do it that's
that's actually that's hilarious dude it
could be that right that's the funniest
[__] thing it's like his great
grandma burned her mouth on soup so from
here on out nobody eat this well it's
rice plus soup you put it all right
people have rage and [__]
to it the other way around and after
that passed down from generation to
generation it could be like that that's
what I'm saying that's why in this house
this is how we eat it it could be that I
mean I I already had like like I like I
said I follow him and I love his [__]
sometimes because some of the things
that I do enjoy that he does he takes a
lot of snobbery out of food um but and
then you felt like hey man like what are
you doing yeah yeah it's a little weird
you know and then
um like for but you know his first faux
pas or his first mistake when he said
that Lee Sandwiches was the best bunny
he's ever had and I was like I gotta
sock you in the face man I like Lee
Sandwiches dude Leaf sandwich is like
the McDonald's of bunnies yeah right but
nobody ever says Lee sandwich is the
best and I [__] with leaves because
that's the good like if you don't have
anything else they make decent bunnies
like it's quick it's fast everybody
knows that [__] yeah but nobody says
Lee's is the best that's like saying
McDonald's the best burger you've ever
had I love McDonald's it's not the best
burger I've ever had you're not gonna
have the like other you know renowned
chefs go and talk about their McDonald's
experiences like everyone knows yeah
come on man if you're if you're doing a
review to this this is new to you no 100
man you're funny like people wanted us
to talk about this but I didn't really
care to because it's passed for so long
and I think because there's a couple of
like ongoing tropes on this podcast if
you guys are new listeners
um I just want to set the record
straight I do not hate semen Lube at all
okay all right I don't hate him at all
everybody thinks I have this virtual
like hate for him what happened this
time so they've been wanting me it
happened like a few weeks ago right and
I'm just going to say it on this podcast
this podcast is sponsored by better help
my lovely genius farce you guys know how
much I love my mental health so I always
gotta check in on it I gotta make sure
that my mental health is popping and
it's all good because if I don't guess
what my physical health will dwindle as
well I found out you know for the past
few years that when I mentally wasn't
right my physical health also decline in
this year it's all about being a better
me so why not do it with better help
what is better help my friends better
help is customize online therapy that
offers video phone and even live chat
sessions with your therapist so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to therapy is all about
deepening your self-awareness and
understanding because sometimes we don't
you know know what we want or why we
react the way that we do or
we don't even know these things until we
really just talk things through and if
you're thinking about starting therapy
just give better help a try it's a lot
more affordable than in person therapy
and you can be matched with a therapist
in under 48 hours so just give it a try
and see why a bunch of people have used
it already discover your potential with
better help visit betterhelp.com genius
today to get 10 off your first month
that's better help
help.com genius I guess it was at a Utah
Jazz game of some sort and you know like
the mega cam thing it's the thing that
you saw
so this [__] right hey man
though but he had to come up because he
played the ISA basketball tournament
back in the day I cried laughing when
you send that [__] to me right so would
you explain to me that the original
because he sent me this photo where I
was edited into this thing so if you
guys don't know what happened on the
Megatron and these All-Star games or
basketball games in general they always
do celebrity look-alikes well it started
with like Kiss cams yeah right kiss cams
got old and then they started doing
staging [__] right but you know what's
new and hot right how celebrity
look-alikes and these celebrities the
Stadium's doing it nobody looks like the
celebrity yeah
right like they don't ever look like the
celebrities I remember one time somebody
they had somebody up they put a minion
on
all right and it was probably just some
bald guy [__] he's wearing glasses or
some [__] right it was [__] hilarious
right and so once again what simu's
superpower is complaining right like
that is his biggest superpower ever
right it's like it's like semen lube and
the [__] seven rings of complaints
that's like his thing right he could
find some random thing not to complain
about and he'll somehow make it about
himself and then complain about it and
say it's for Asian people yeah and this
is like his biggest criticism and
remember when we first criticized him
about the stuff everybody was jumping
down our throats saying how dare you do
this to our [__] semen Loop and I was
like listen keep calling him semen so
I don't feel any certain way about him
like I don't think about this dude at
all but y'all keep bringing him up if
he's like a roaster everyone wants like
I I see it in the comments it's like man
why is he why does he keep coming up to
you yeah because they want me to roast
him so bad because other other Asian
influencers won't do it right even when
they know that he's doing things that
are [__] blatantly wrong and highly
narcissistic nobody will do it because
he is The Seven Rings guy yeah right so
they're looking for me to do it is it
ten rings I don't know
so look
set the record straight I don't dislike
I don't feel anything about him right
right we only talk about this the topics
that come up the reason why this wasn't
uh something big to talk about because
what's new I've said this about him
already right we said just wait till
something pops up he'll complain about
it he'll whine about it and he won't
know any of the background behind it
even though he loves playing basketball
apparently and he'll make it
you know all us Asians right guys right
right all of us right and so yeah and he
got chewed up for that tweet once again
because it's not that serious it's not
that serious
but it
okay well let's let's explain what it is
so it was a celebrity look-alike and
because it was a celebrity All-Star game
that SEMA was playing in which is like
grants to him to do that but obviously
if you saw the highlights my hero DK
Metcalf MVP but anyway
um he probably cried about that too hey
you made one of those long four-point
shots or whatever but anyway
um so they're doing the celebrities
that's on the court on the screen and
like saying haha who looks like the
celebrity like they always do but when I
put simu's photo up there they just pick
some random Asian kid right hilarious
yeah it's like
it's also the like
like they don't give a [__] yeah where
I'm like damn and it's like everybody
else got roasted and then he's the one
guy that gets roasted he goes that's not
cool
like dude I'm that's all I'm saying this
guy has no friends or no friends that
tell them to shut the [__] up you know
what I was thinking that poor kid
serious
the world was like Hey you look like him
and he was like that's [__] up
hideous as this Asian guy right here
Jesus look at this guy's just like dude
what the [__] man
he probably the only Asian kid in Utah
dude that post that you put up with it
was like my photo on it
because it looks more like you like the
old years when I free Lasik you that's
why when you sent that I didn't know
that simu's face was On It originally
yeah because it looked like me she
looked like me
so I was cracking the [__] up I'm like
damn that's pretty accurate oh [__] he's
standing up for me yeah and I thought he
was like see movie was standing up for
me I'm like and in my mind even then I
thought dude he looks like me so the
contest guys so I took that tweet from
simu but instead of sema's face I put
deep David's old face on it from like
2012 and then he looked way more like
the kid and and so that even that got me
the most [__] likes I got on my
[__] Instagram stories ever hilarious
and I'll tell you that he really did
look like me he looks like you so even
when I saw that I thought that simulu
was defending me I got annoyed because
I'm like dude he actually looks like me
you know it's actually pretty accurate
I hope you save that photo so you use
that as the thumbnail for this one I'll
send it over to me it's on your stories
right yeah I'm gonna put it as on my
Instagram
um post
it cracked me the [__] up because it
legit looked like me but this is what
I'm talking about right the guy doesn't
know how to just shut the [__] up you
know about things that he doesn't need
to speak up on like this wasn't
something that wasn't a [__] issue
there was no Asian people that were
upset about this but you but then you
made it seem like you're standing up for
Asian people just shut the [__] up like
dude I already booked another movie
congrats your fuckulations post about
that post about your successes post
about the things that you're [__]
killing it on stop [__] crying dude
stop whining I think it's
there's so much going on for you like
why why does it I don't understand what
it is is it like it has to be perfect
every time like or is it like some
semblance of
like I must be treated a certain way
because I am now a movie star because I
am a movie star so people need to
respect me how come I'm not getting the
respect like somebody like Leonardo
DiCaprio all these uh these other
celebrities don't get treated this way
you know why Simo because they did more
films than just Shang Chi which was
terrible hey cheers bro
let's do this let's see who's doing the
talking like you're heated though you're
heated I'm so UPS I'm irritated because
it's like dude I'm like he's he's
staying low he's killing it he's doing
well and this guy that we're trying to
Champion he keeps putting his foot in
his mouth that's true because the the
biggest traction he keeps getting is the
stuff he complains about exactly and
it's not good publicity it makes us look
so bad as Asian Americans it makes us
look so bad because he says he's our
hero but the the why it for me why it
makes me feel like it makes us look bad
is because he gets like 80 000 likes in
those complaints and I'm like oh man all
these [__] complaining with
them oh you guys who like those [__]
you're a [__] too dude stop gassing him
up dude like gas him up for the [__]
that he's doing well booking films you
know what I mean that's the stuff that
we should be celebrating for him right
don't celebrate him whining because you
feel like you're this dejected Asian you
know what I mean yeah like it doesn't do
anything for us because we need to
complain about the things that are worth
complaining about because after a while
people get tired of that [__] they just
go up here they go again because if we
really want to talk about then we're not
just talking about him this is just like
Asian celebrities alone this is what I
[__] hate about Asian celebrities
they're the most sometimes a lot of them
are so obnoxious because I've heard and
you know these people are in the stories
I see them on Instagram you talk so much
[__] about like Asian representation in
film and this is the only thing you care
about when our people were getting
burned alive on these streets you didn't
say [__] you didn't say [__] you weren't
protesting you didn't post about any of
that stuff but oh I didn't get to be in
a film and then you're posting about
that non-stop but when we're getting
[__] up out there you just did one
little post you were not you weren't you
weren't [__] you know adamant about
helping people out you didn't talk about
it on your platforms but what you're
very vocal about is the reason why you
didn't get picked for a part in a
[__] movie so [__] you you don't do
[__] for our community and you sit there
and you act like you're [__]
important and you're not you're not
important I'm not important none of us
are that [__] important and I hate
the snobbery behind that [__] that's why
it [__] annoys me right so when I see
people for example right and I'll use
this as an example
I'm not saying China Mac is a perfect
person right yeah he has a lot of flaws
however he was the one that was the most
active during the time where we were
getting punked and bullied yeah we have
these events celebrating people who were
doing great things for our community he
wasn't mention one yeah yeah that's true
and he wasn't invited to any of the
other any other stuff why is that blows
my [__] you know why because he
doesn't fit the perfect perfect image of
what an Asian American should be even
though he is doing the most for us
that's a a bit of a weird uh what is
that called hypocrisy because if we
don't want to be the model minority then
China Mac is the perfect example of how
he is not the model minority no right
they do want to be the model minority
they love it yeah but also the model
minority the anti-model minority is
speaking up and complaining now
apparently right like we can we have
voices and we speak up right but then
when it's the little things like not all
Asians look alike and that gets like
thousands of likes hey new songs
and it's not a bad thing it's like for
us like it's a it's a pretty good skill
to to be able to see a Chinese person
and say they're Chinese you're a
Japanese person they're Japanese you
know and like dictate each one of them
completely right the only Asians that
look different are Hmong people that's
it that [__] I can see you guys
from a mile away dude yeah and strong B
boys
I don't know what it is it's it I felt
like
there was a a schoolyard aspect to it
right because of like even to when
I'll be honest so I saw this post
where this Asian mom is telling the
story about her daughter daughter's
classmate who's sharing her Korean food
with her at the lunch and she's crying
because it didn't happen like that for
her right it was such a beautiful video
but for me I was heated like because I'm
Petty
I'm like man these [__] kids today
they're like knowing all this peace and
[__] they don't know what it was like
and I'm like hmm I'm being salty as [__]
why do I want gen Z to suffer
I suffered I'm like oh [__] that's like
old people
that's that old old man like thinking
kind of thing I'm like oh yeah then you
know the weird thing about these like
conversations like we'll say stuff like
this right and they go oh you're just
bitter because you weren't Shang Chi I'm
like is that
is that what you got from this
conversation
is that what you think you became this
because you lost the role you wish you
were in their position yes I wish I was
rich yeah of course
but do you think I wouldn't be saying
the same [__] thing if I had their
position yeah I would be saying the same
[__] thing which problematic for me
is probably why I'm not in their
position yeah
and listen I've heard from other Asian
celebrities that you guys [__] know
that know who the [__] I am I've been to
every single one of these parties and
guess what they said to me people are
scared of me
because you because I don't get that
[__] cause I talk that [__] and guess
what that made me feel [__] good
I made me feel amazing because you're
free because I'm free I'm like damn so
you guys think the same way I do but you
won't say anything I get it but that's
no hate though I get it
you are in a unique position amongst
your peers a hundred percent and I get
it I [__] get it you guys need to
play nice you didn't make your jobs do
what you do I can't change who I am
though I'm gonna do what I do and I'm
gonna stay on this YouTube platform and
Spotify and everything else because I
get to create the way that I want to
create I get to say my [__] I get to
call semen see my little semen Lube yeah
right as a joke because I'm a jokester
right but you won't do it even if you
think it's funny you won't say it
because you're afraid of what if his
agent contacts my agent and they go oh
you were talking bad about him so he's
scared to work with you on a project
[__] all that [__] this is comedy baby
we make jokes
and that's what I love that's why
sometimes I love standing Comics they
don't give a [__] dog when [__]
Brendan shot put out his shitty stand-up
special dude his peers were roasting him
yeah you know what I mean but he had the
[__] guts to do it exactly and it's
not a problem that's why I love stand-up
comedy sometimes right they even at the
highest level they could still roast
each other and it's not a big [__]
issue and so when it comes to sometimes
with the Hollywood stuff
and Joe Rogan has said it himself like
Hollywood is poison like this is just a
bunch of fake handshakes and people
smiling just to get jobs because they're
scared that they're gonna lose their
positions yeah and originally when it
came to a lot of like the Asian
Americans they were like oh we need to
set a better standard for um what
Hollywood is supposed to be because
they've um they they're Gatekeepers and
they won't allow us in guess what now
you're Gatekeepers too right you're the
same [__] thing that you were [__]
protesting about complaining about
you're the same [__] [__] so hard
yeah so hard I've seen it too the
gatekeeping as if like this is my
position and my spot and you can't have
it you have an idea how many [__]
meetings I've had with people where I'm
so sick of it or they try to take my
life story and they want to turn into
this fluffy [__] and then try to
gatekeep my story they're like oh that's
cool but we can't put that in no [__]
you yeah when you're not changing my
life story because it better suits like
a white palette you're doing the same
thing you're doing the same thing or
you're doing it because it better suits
the [__] model minority palette how
are you any different yeah the same
[__] the same thing that you hate
people for you you just became that same
monster and that's why I want nothing to
do with that [__] if you want me to be a
project I'll audition for if you want to
hire me then there's a lot of [__] that
comes with it a lot of honesty I feel
like maybe this attitude is because
these Asian Americans are the model
minority yeah and they're trying to
break out of it by being anti that and
being anti what they thought was
themselves but then kind of losing it in
this
I hate using the terminology this way
but in the walk sphere yeah yeah because
of what it's become because of the
culture on Twitter and of what it's
become these model minority Asians want
to be anti-model minority and as if
they're like like I said the main
character syndrome where they had to
come from nothing or something or they
had a tougher upbringing and they don't
want to mention that they grew up in a
very nice neighborhood the parents did
very well and then they just their black
sheep stories that they want to be an
actor yeah and look that's why I say
like I know when you're hearing this
podcast like damn this this little got
some [__] ammo for everybody but not
true you don't if you want to follow me
on Instagram there are more people I
celebrate than I put down right like we
just did like a whole 10-minute session
about how much I appreciate Cassie ho
right and what she does as a Creator
right dude Justin Chon [__] kills it
right him as a director in the project
that he's creating is very very [__]
important you know what I'm saying
there's Benedict one of my favorite
Asian American oh not American he's a
British actor yeah yeah but you know
club man but and what you're seeing out
of the people that we are talking about
is that they are expressing themselves
through their work yeah yeah yeah yeah
you know and their Grievous since that
that they have gets translated and
expressed perhaps maybe because he
doesn't get a space to have that
grievance expressed because he's doing
Disney projects now
right and they're not gonna talk about
the Asian attacks and Asian hate in the
shangshi movies
maybe he's they've got to now speak
about it on the Twitter verse yeah and
then shooting Miss dude and look
everything everywhere all at once
[__] taking everybody's oh my gosh
they they just swept the SAG Awards now
wrecked everybody dude let's go yeah
amazing come on now downstairs come on
now amazing and it's [__] well
deserved there are two people who I know
that were just these kids who did
martial arts like Andy and Brian yeah
they were up there on stage for their
choreography for the fight card that
they learned themselves self-taught
[__] amazing those guys [__]
weirdos by the way but really dope at
what they do they're gonna put respect
on their name hell [__] yeah I'm
gonna put some respect on their [__]
names man those guys literally two
brothers that practice themselves
self-taught and look at how much time
and dedication they put into their craft
right you don't ever hear them talk
about [__] right they just work on
their [__] craft and they let their
[__] hard work speak for themselves
Annie Lee and Brian Lee yeah follow them
check them out you'll see how [__]
hard they work these guys are long
they've been doing it too right yeah
they're [__] amazing you'd never hear
them complain about the reason why I'm
not representing no they just so you
know what I'm [__] dope and my ex
Excellence will be recognized because I
am excellent at what I do you know where
I first saw them I first saw them at
collaboration 2009. that's the shrine
theater oh really and they do this
freestyle dance competition and so they
bring people up just to dance freestyle
right and then then Andy and Brian Lee
came on stage and they were just doing
Kung Fu moves and flipping and all that
[__] right now they didn't win because
it was like not dancing yeah but look at
this they've been still doing that and
they perfected like they're they're
mastering their craft and now they've
made an oscar-worthy [__] film dude
and they're passionate about that [__]
which is why it's so [__] inspiring
dude and so well sometimes when I see
some of these other people who are on
the space who want to complain about
they're not giving they're not getting
their due Justice in terms of like film
and acting you're not passionate about
this you're passionate about wanting to
be recognized but you're not passionate
about acting you suck you [__] suck
I've seen your work you're terrible I'm
only saying this too because if you want
to talk that [__] your work has to match
that right right you know you have your
work has to match that [__] you have
never ever heard me complain about me oh
God I was never in blockbuster movies
you know why because I suck
I mean I'm a at best like a c-level
actor right if I was putting my heart
and soul into this and I truly believe
that I'm putting out some of the best
performances there I might be able to
say something but I'm not I know where
I'm at you know what I'm saying and I
think that self-awareness is what a lot
of people don't understand they want to
complain about the opportunities that
they don't get when they haven't even
worked for the opportunities that they
should have I think it's probably
because they're they're self-worth is
being measured by their metrics on the
studio model look at how many followers
this guy has look at the engagement he
gets look at the this and that look at
the how much money his last movie made
despite the fact like we didn't like it
you know yeah it it in it the Hollywood
model is so shallow that what gives you
your self-worth is the most
and it's almost nothing in your control
I'll give you a great example right so
somebody like Michelle yo when she talks
about like the state of Hollywood and
representation I listen to her you know
why because she's been through it
she has her body of work speaks for it
[__] self first Asian American Bond
girl right or not amazing America just
Asian Bond girl was that and then what's
his name killed it too uh
the guy who played uh her husband wait a
minute no women on the uh yeah
he
he I don't know why I'm blanking on this
right now but you know he's been through
it yeah you know he thought his career
was dead and they gave him a chance and
he revived it and showed how um he's
he's such an amazing actor he was so
good in that film and when was the last
time he had an opportunity to show it
off but they just remembered him as the
kid from Indiana Jones yeah that was it
and everyone I bet everyone called him
Short Round exactly everyone call him
data and now look at him yeah right by
the way he has the chance to say
something about his experience and we
listen to people like that not because
of the body of not like the level of
work he's done but the dues that he's
paid and the body of work and also what
he has shown that he can do in that film
so there's a lot it doesn't sound like
complaints it sounds like a it sounds
like it's coming from a place of from a
genuine Place experience right I've been
there yeah also what's his name 94 year
old uh James James Hong how many times
have first of all I know James Hunt from
Jerry Stein from Seinfeld right so I've
had people football and a lot of other
other films that
his credit
a big trouble little China you see them
from everywhere right yeah so when he
when he went up on stage and he said I
remember a time where people said that
Asian people weren't Blockbuster I felt
that [__] and it made me so happy to see
him get what he deserved but once again
the things that he says we perceive and
receive it very well because of his
position in life because of the body of
work that he's put in so not just not
just see me right this is beyond him
right he's just a small little example
but from other people in this space who
are Asian actors
you guys who are just auditioning who
who aren't very you guys aren't good
right yet
because you're you're comparing yourself
to people like Michelle yo who are you
you are not them you don't have the the
dedication that the craft the dedicate
you haven't even dedicated yourself to
the craft even complained the way that
you do so the immediate thing that you
go into when you go into an audition
because you didn't book it is because
you're Asian it's because you [__]
suck
that's why yeah right and once again I'm
not saying that you can't get better
that you're not going to get better you
just started so because you just started
you're gonna have to pay your dues a
little bit everybody's going through
that same [__] and right now Asian
people are hot yeah they're hot so guess
what you're not getting these rolls
you're also not that good yet but like
from what Xiang Chi did for him it's
like his name is gonna be at the top of
the list of so many projects now yeah
he's gonna book anything and everything
now it doesn't matter what so it's like
who the [__] cares if this kid looks
like you exactly dude one of my buddies
put it the best right
so he he was complaining to a mutual
friend of ours right about me right and
he was like why is David being like such
a [__] towards me blah blah blah and
then you know what he said to him he
goes he he said to him he goes why do
you care what David says you're on the
cover of like Time Magazine
which is a hundred percent true he goes
why do you care about everything that
every little person says about you like
David does a podcast and you were a
topic because it was news like why do
you care did it affect your bank account
um did it affect your Fame like what are
you talking about what why does
everything bother you so much why does
what David says bother you so much like
you're being weird about it right and
guess what now he doesn't talk to him
anymore either because somebody opposed
what he was thinking and that was a big
tell sign for me I was like oh you you
just don't like people who disagree with
you you like being in the do you want
people to Pat you on the ass and say
you're doing a great investment in your
life and guess what that's going to
create you a lot of enemies a lot of
[__] enemies I have a lot of enemies
well deserved
it's very well deserved I get it you
know but for somebody like him or just
any other like actor out there you know
who I'm on I say for me and this is my
opinion and obviously I think a lot of
people are going to disagree with this
they'll bring up their own personal
experiences which is perfectly fine I
think that sometimes before you start
complaining think about what you have
done to deserve the spot that you think
that you're allowed to complain like
this
I don't ever complain about the roles I
haven't booked or have booked or
whatever because
um there's always room to grow and get
better and if I want things to change
I'll make the change for myself you know
what I'm saying yeah yeah so when I see
other actors too where you know we I had
a mutual friend story in the podcast
where she hasn't talked to me she got
mad at me because I basically told her
like I don't like it when you sit here
and you talk [__] about other people who
book roles that you didn't get simply
because they put in the work and you did
it
you know [__] got mad at me
[__] upset and I was like here's the
difference you're talking [__] about
them
they're not talking [__] about you they
actually respect what you do but you
don't respect what they do and that's
probably why they're getting these roles
and you aren't
you know what I mean because they're
they're in their Lane like social media
stars are this social media stars are
that that's cool that's their Lane if
you're good at what you do you'll book
[__] you'll be fine yeah I think it's
like just deep-seated
um negativity or resentment possibly
because
how do I say this there's like
there's times when jealousy is good
right where it's like damn that guy got
that
I want that too and so that jealousy is
gonna motivate you to get what that
person got too right because that's
something you want
now there's a negative sign of that and
that's called Envy
or it's like
um damn that guy got that she doesn't
deserve it I should have got that yeah
and that's where it's a problem that's
where it's a problem and then it's like
then they start destroying others like
we said they become the gatekeeper so
they must be the one they must be the
one yeah when there's so many doors
opening yeah and that's the thing too
that's a very good tell like when you
feel like oh that should be a role that
I should have that's a very bad way to
think you should be celebrating the fact
that somebody got that role right you
could still critique
you know their performance or whatever
but if you feel like you know you could
have done a better job and you hate them
for it that's a little weird you could
feel like you could do it but you
shouldn't hate that person for it right
like nobody dislikes simulu because he
became shangshi I think that's pretty
amazing right we just did a review of
the film that was it I mean we didn't
even know who was no we didn't
have to be honest right yeah it's like
the thing is like this thing puts you up
there into this fear of just like World
recognition
complaining about Asian kids who look
like you yeah this is weird I don't know
yeah it's like no you're you're good man
you were on G I think it was on GQ he
was on Time Magazine I guess like we
were just talking about NBA All-Star
celebrity game like damn okay yeah you
know what I'm saying like Indian Barbie
he's gonna be in Barbie also she's
making millions bro you're killing it
why do you complain so much it's almost
like he he likes being the person that's
the Down and Out human being that's what
he thrives off of the underdog yeah the
main character syndrome it's weird you
know what I mean like no matter how
successful he is he'll find a way to
complain about life or complain about
himself or why people don't respect him
or something but I think that's the
thing I dislike the most about it you
know what I mean like I don't know him
personally but clearly he has a very
specific Trope in his in his character
line in real life that is showing yeah
right so once you do it once okay maybe
twice all right maybe three times four
times five times six times okay
and by the way once again there are
things that I know about him that I will
never tell on this podcast that a lot a
lot of people Seema if you're ever
listening to this you need to do better
with uh not sharing so much information
about yourself to people because people
talk
hahaha
I ain't no rat but once again your peers
are not your peers ah the victim of
oversharing exactly you know what I mean
when you do stupid [__] people talk
people share even if people shake your
hand and they say sharing you're doing
you're doing a great job that's not what
they tell me
but look Welcome to Hollywood Welcome to
Hollywood once again that's not even his
fault that's what Hollywood is yeah it's
a bunch of people who will say some of
the most despicable things about a human
being and the next day post that they're
killing it smile right in your face
[Music]
happy for you bro I hate it I [__]
hate that [__] it makes me feel s it
makes me feel gross you know that I and
I have to be in this space with these
people have to pretend to laugh all the
time can't do it that's why I stopped
going to those [__] Galas yeah it's
all full of people like that and these
are once again Asian American who said
that they're better than these people
but you do the same thing
and it makes me upset because you were
on your moral high horse about it and
now you've become that same [__]
beast that you were criticizing so it's
hard for me not to say something and
it's hard for me not to show it on my
face how much I hate you [__]
you know
and then people like have you seen that
video of that shark swimming around you
see these fish flying away yeah that's
me I'm the shark right they go oh be
careful David's gonna speak his mind
yeah of course I am dude of course I am
what did you think was gonna happen I
don't give a [__] you don't affect my
[__] paycheck life life is good
you're not beholden to other people's
opinions
you either yeah and also too it's like
because I'm not important none of us are
that important you know what I mean
we're all gonna die and that's where
that freedom comes from if you don't
give a [__] what other people say about
you like you have a lot more freedom to
feel like to say saying [__]
yeah and also I I only have to care
about the people that matter to me right
and one day somebody comes with me I
didn't like what you said about this I'm
like all right
your mom's a [__]
but if someone you love and respect came
to you hey David yeah and then we'll
talk about it I'll be like hey well
let's talk about what did what didn't
you like about them we'll have a long
in-depth conversation but even then a
lot of my friends don't want that smoke
either
you know by the way like a stubborn
[__] like we'll talk you know
and I we've we look it's happened
multiple times right
and once again usually what happens is
like they'll listen to a podcast or they
heal something that somebody else has
and they talk to me and they go oh
that's not what it's not what I thought
it was right yeah of course it is and
I'm glad you came and you talked to me
about it right and uh definitely too
like with um the
um what's it called um criticism of like
Shang Chi oh I got a lot of messages
yeah it wasn't that bad I'll go watch it
again yeah three weeks later chill go
watch that [__] again after you're done
with the hype because you're happy that
you just got to go outside and watch a
movie every single one without fail
yeah you know
I said and I said go go back and listen
to my podcast and see if I was being a
hater or if we were just doing a movie
review and they go oh [__] you're just
doing a movie review just like we've
done with other ones
what was the difference I think it was
the people who live in the social media
space who definitely felt the flavor in
the air of Asian American excellence and
then we all saw the movie didn't see
Excellence yeah we were because we were
expecting Excellence dude everything
everywhere all at once that is X was the
film for us I'm so happy it's getting so
many rewards Awards because I know we
need that
we need that so bad that was what the
MCU needs yes and they're [__] you
know sphere of all these [__] movies
you know but what we got is what we got
in that and then
thank God for everything I wrote
everywhere all that wants to show us
like
how it can be done Asian American films
you know and not behold into the Chinese
government films yeah yeah yeah yeah and
so like I said uh if you guys haven't
watched everything everywhere all at
once I suggest you do watch it and this
is winning all the awards now and
there's a good goddamn reason for it
right yeah and I'll go back to um uh
crazy Rich Asians if that [__] won
awards it would have killed me
it would have literally killed me on the
inside because we're like [__] is this
how what we say is our best yeah is this
what people are gonna think like Asian
American cinema this is the standard
that we're setting yeah and you know
once again that was also another film
that later on people were like oh [__]
it wasn't that good you know I is
because I understand you wanted to see
familiar faces on the screen and you got
caught up in that I get it keep saying
it's because everyone forgot about Joy
Luck Club everyone forgot about Harold
and Kumar yeah everyone forgot about the
other Classics too and they're like
we've never had this it's like yes we
have
years we have you're jumping on the hype
train we need it but don't act like this
never happened before like Jackie Chan
is not a superstar yeah Rush Hour was
not a [__] amazing movie people are
screaming for Rush Hour 4 to be racist
together and we need that and we want
him that way for God's sake we needed
that if there's no racist jokes tonight
watching this [__] it's no good it's no
good without the racism look I love it
man I think we've had more
representation is better but
representation should be done in a
really good way where we can be uh
respected as such so when people see
things they go oh this is amazing yeah
because if it ended with crazy Rich
Asians I would have been [__]
devastated
you know what I mean I would have been
devastated so once again congratulations
to the whole cast of everything
everywhere all at once Annie Lee Brian
Lee man I've seen you guys just do your
[__] in silence and you guys are finally
getting recognized for the hard work
that you put in simply doing what you're
doing I celebrate you highly you're
[__] amazing keep doing what you're
[__] doing everybody is recognizing
all the hard work you've put in
um Michelle yo
sexy ass Michelle yo
I love you so much amazing actress was a
supermodel too by the way the whole
[__] package very well put together
um
James Hong congratulations you [__]
did it
right and man the directors too the
Daniels because they were just doing
goofy music videos and then they made
one of the most meaningful movies in the
last 50 years them too amazing dude
[__] amazing like we were only
talking about the actors but let's talk
about the Daniels like look at what
they've done by the way too going from
music video to film it doesn't usually
happen linear always translate well at
all like I've seen it before I've worked
with a guy who did music videos and he
tried to do a short it was terrible yeah
the when with music videos there's no
rules so you don't have to tear and tell
a narrative they're very seldom like
very great narrative telling music video
like and Commercial directors who end up
making really great film um uh David
Fincher used to be a music video
director amazing and then came out and I
was making dope ass films hey Michael
Bay made music videos and Victoria's
Secret commercials and that still
translates hey it makes sense yeah it
makes his whole movie looks like a
Victoria's Secret commercial exactly
that's it was the uh the girl who played
uh Michelle Yo's daughter what's her
name my follower she's amazing uh yeah
I'm sorry yeah the name's blanking out
on me but she's been regulated for best
uh supporting actress
yeah dude she's so [__] good she's
such an amazing actress once again if
she started complaining I would
understand you know what I mean I would
get it like look
um like I said it's all about
celebrating the great things once again
I also celebrate uh simulu as well like
you know I don't know his personal story
I heard he wrote a book or some [__]
like that
um but at the end of the day like look
I'm a happy he's a superhero or whatever
right but just shut the [__] up every
now and then hey here's a great example
uh Rose the girl Tran oh yeah Marie Tran
dealt a horrible [__] card from
Disney and the script she was given and
the way the [__] fans hated her
she [__] stuck it out kept their chin
High
stayed silent like
when she had every reason to be like
[__] these [__] in this whole
universe
but she stays strong and like
and like I mean I'm sure she has all
these complaints to say you know and I'm
not saying she shouldn't have but man
and then she did uh the voice in Raya
and such yeah like dude same was nowhere
close to getting attacked like some Star
Wars fans attacking Rosemary train yeah
I'm saying man like if if people always
wondered too it's like I've been like
well you sure as they'll talk a lot
about him for somebody who doesn't care
about him you keep asking me to what are
your thoughts yeah it's like it's and
it's also a podcast you know so this is
what it is like I said
I'm gonna keep cheering for him but I'm
still gonna criticize him every time he
does some stupid [__] that sets us back
a few years I have to and you guys
should too if you see something that you
know isn't right say some [__] about
that you know so it's the loudest voices
that seem to be the representatives of
us and they're like hey who asked you
yeah and also he doesn't have to give a
[__] about what any of us think yeah you
know and we can definitely be ignored oh
a hundred percent and he's not giving a
foul he he does which is weird I don't
understand that [__] at all like dude
you're you're just some [__] guy man
and just some [__] guy yeah but you
know once again on a level of positivity
shout outs to see Malu congratulations
on Shang Chi he just he's going to do
another movie with um Nora and John Cena
I saw that yeah I saw that news hey
congratulations hilarious because John
Cena's our hero dude and are we pissed
that he's working with John Cena no no
that's [__] dope because John Cena's
dope yeah congratulations to you so I'm
super excited to see what that film's
gonna try out to be it's gonna be a
comedy movie yeah so big action comedy
action comedy so we're gonna we're gonna
get to see like see malu's acting chop
see if it [__] translates and once
again I'm hoping he [__] kills it so
we want you to win yeah like I wanted to
shut everybody up including me right so
if he comes out and this movie is
amazing guess who's gonna sing his
Praises first
me and me and Ed will talk about it
we'll be like dude he was [__]
amazing but until then you suck so
everything we are unimpressionable Asian
parents yeah we are we are the
definition of Asian parents
um
well guys that wraps up this episode of
The Genius brain podcast uh catch genius
brain every Sunday at 12 p.m uh
streaming every Thursday at 7 p.m on the
channel uh Davidson comedy and then we
will see you all next time you can catch
Ed at edparkvp and also his podcast
Bible study at Momo you see in a month